hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the 1916 New York
rice tournament a Capablanca is without
a loss so far this is round ten and the
only game the capablanca didn't win was
the previous one in round nine that was
the draw and here he faces offered
shredder now I haven't found any
information on this gentleman so we are
once again honoring the hoodie guy by
wearing a hoodie I do hope you you are
doing the same as well you know to it
further enjoy the game but it's really
an impressive game and if you remember I
think it was last year we've shown a
game between Michael tal and honza
Karolyi we're tall was wasn't very
pleased that Cara Lee didn't play the
best defense as tall really prepared a
really complicated combination and then
he couldn't show it in the game because
his opponent it didn't play the best
defense and here it's a it's similar
game so I'm sure you're gonna enjoy it
and it's really a 15 move line that
Capablanca prepared but better better
just if I show it to you and unlike for
all the other games that were played in
New York in various clubs in various
chess club's this one was actually
played in Yale University so if any of
you are perhaps studying in Yale
University do know that this game
Capablanca versus redder was played in
your university so without further ado
Blanca has the white pieces and of
course we have a d4 on the board you
don't have to be an expert on this
channel to know that we will have the
Queen's Gambit the client on the board
we have c4 and Knight to f6 with Knight
to c3 by Capablanca 9b d7 Bishop to g5
all pretty standard the Bishop to e7
both sides just developing III shredder
castles and now rook to c1 by kappa
blanka a6 black is waiting with the
capture on c4 he's waiting for a couple
bunker to develop the light square
bishop as is it is customary Queen to c2
and now rook to e8 as black has plenty
of useful moves so he can really just
wait for white to develop the light
square Bishop Bishop to d3 and of course
only now does he capture on c4 Bishop
captures and now takes well the awkward
position of the light square bishop
means of expanding on the queenside so
b5 but should be back to d3 still
pressuring that hh7 pawn bishop to b7
black now finally solves the problem of
developing the light square bishop and
here kappa blanka has a couple of moves
to choose from he decides to attack the
flank on the Queen side with a for
inviting black the push forward would be
for and here kappa blanka can go Knight
to e4 but first he decides for Bishop
captures on f6 and okay Knight captures
on f6 we enter a series of trades Knight
to e4 Knight captures Bishop captures
Bishop captures and now Queen captures
and here c5 a very nice idea of a black
a very principled idea you want to get
rid of your backwards pawn attacking
couple on has very strong center but it
is a temporary pawn sacrifice so
Capablanca captures that we have D
captures on c5 and now you still can't
capture back because the rook is
defending it Queen to a5 and here Cup
Blanca has to make a choice where does
he go c6 or does he capture on a4 c6 and
allowing black to capture on a4 is one
way to do it then you have a very strong
passed pawn and on c6 but black will
simply move the Queen and start pushing
his own passport and create a past upon
which will be an outside pass pawn so
it's you know it is playable but
Capablanca decides to go for a different
idea after Queen to a5 capablanca plays
b3 defends the a4 pawn and gives up the
c5 pawn instead Bishop captures on c5
and now Knights the g5 capablanca is
threatening to capture on h7 and here
you can either block with the g6 or you
can play what was played in the game
which isn't something everyone would
play here g6 is the most likely option
that most of us would go for and then
after Queen to e5 just lining up the
Queen with the white queen with the
black Queen on a5 black can go here you
can trade Queens and then play the same
game where couple Blanca has a knight
and his opponent has a bathroom but the
pawns are on the Queen side r are all on
light squares so that the bishop would
be in somewhat of a disadvantage
unlike the night it's a I mean it's a
very strong night so here our shredder
decides he does not want to play this
end game against Capablanca and he
actually decides to go for h6 he allows
capablanca to infiltrate with the Queen
and he sets what seems to be a very
deadly trap for a cup of Wonka or does
he but I mean he does but he just
doesn't know he doesn't hear a cup of
man who goes for it Queen to h7 check we
have king to f8 and now you should
probably go back with the knight Knight
to e4 and then everything is perfectly
fine for black but capablanca finds a
different idea he plays Queen tha with
check we have kingka e7 and now both
Capablanca Queen and the knight are
under attack but capablanca has
everything figured out he decides to
sacrifice the night he plays Queen
captures on g7 with H capture Sun g5
capablanca gives up a night and now
Queen captures and g5 with check King to
d6 and now we have King to e2 getting
the King away from a dark square
there's no danger now but you know the
position could easily open up and then
something like bushel captures you could
blunder your queen I mean that's not the
only reason he does it he also wants to
get his rook into the game
we have rook a to c8 black starts
developing his rooks and rook the c4 a
nice rook lifts and he here capablanca
is preparing rook H 2 c1 to double up
the other the tada Brooks and the C file
King to c6 black wants to hide the king
all the way over to the Queen side we
have rook H 2 c1 kappa blanka now
successfully doubles rook on the Queen
side and king moves king to be six so
this was couple Blancas plan this is
what couple blanca saw when he
sacrificed the night on g5 he's up two
points but he's down a bishop but he
does have a pest h bond and well that
passed h point is a very fast bond so
what do you do with a passed pawn of
course all of you know you simply push
it and here this is exactly what couple
blanca does he pushes the pawn to h4 and
this is the moment where Capablanca
doesn't feel his opponent played the the
absolute best defense here
his opponent played f5 and this is a
move that doesn't do all that much
what Capablanca was preparing on what
Capablanca showed after the game because
he kappa blanka was awarded the
brilliancy prize for this game and there
we have the quote above the board by
bill hearthstone that also talks about
this game what we shouldn't forget is
that it takes two very good players to
create a brilliant game I always fill
the role of the loser in a brilliancy is
underestimated and harson also said that
he feels that the loser should be
awarded the money for the brilliancy
price because the winner is well he's
he's happy because he played a brilliant
game so the money should go to the loser
but regardless capablanca showed after
the game but rather I'm just gonna show
you how the game went on and then I'm
gonna show you what capablanca presented
after the game here we have f5 by
shredder and now comes Queen to g7
Michael Blanca preparing to remove word
acquainted over to e5 we have looked to
e7 attacking the Queen Queen to e5 and
now blacks last hope was to play
something like rook to c7 just guarding
the c5 bishop but then you lose the e6
pawn and after King moves you're gonna
lose the F of five point as well and
here kappa blanka would be up four
points and four points is more than
enough compensation for the piece so
this would be winning for white but here
a couple on his opponent actually played
rook to c6 he said I'm gonna play rook
to c6 then I'm gonna bring the
autorecover to c7 so my rook from east
six will be defending the six pawn but
it simply doesn't work here kappa blanka
played one move and his opponent
resigned the game but feel free to pause
the video here and try to figure out
what was the move Capablanca played in
this position I'll give you a couple of
seconds to decide whether we want to do
it as usual while I have a nice approve
my water for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are once
again an excellent finder of moves that
haven't didn't happen in the game and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show here a couple Blanca played
rook captures on c5 which actually did
happen in the game after rook a present
c5 alfred Treader resigned the game
because now you see after a recapture
with the Queen and then you lose the
queen or
actress and then comes Queen d6 check
and now you can either grab the rook or
just trap the black queen after
roadblocks you will play rook captures
and after king b7
now you go rook c5 and the black queen
is trapped there's nowhere to go I mean
you could go to b6 but then you
certainly lose the rook let's say you go
Queen b6 than just Queen captures on a7
you wrap a whole rook completely winning
but mr. Alfred shredder did not wait for
this after this rook to c5 he resigned
the game after this rook the c5 here
yeah after we captured on c5 he resigned
the game but why I said couple monka
wasn't happy about this position because
here after h4 cover Blanca had a
completely different idea in line the
one that doesn't tell our cover Blanca
to infiltrate so easily here Capablanca
presented the following series of moves
after the game
rook the c7 this is what couple Lanka
had in mind
for black to double up on the C file
Capablanca would push the pawn to h5
rook eat the c8 now black doubles up on
the C file as well h6 by Capablanca and
now Bishop to d6 here black can just
trade down and he will be left with a
piece in the endgame where white will
not have any pieces and this is what
couple Blanca had in mind Queen captures
on a5 King captures on a5 real capture
sense e7 rook captures rook captures
Bishop captures and here F for a very
nice move that doesn't allow bishop tip
sorry Bishop to e5 to control the
queening square that is the 88 square
but here black can still catch up to the
h8 square just bush up to d8 now you can
go Bishop f6 controlled ehh square but
couple Blanca goes g4 and the pawn storm
is just too powerful Bishop to f6 but
now comes g5 Bishop h8 and now II four
and the black king is simply too slow
king b6 now comes f5 e captures pawn
captures the King now tries to catch up
to the pawns but the g6 is coming F
captures pawn captures and now there is
no defense against g7 King b6 but Judge
g7 the black king is too slow captures
captures and if you try to catch up to
the pawn of course you will not be able
to do it white will bring
Queen into the game and white of course
is completely winning here so this is
what Capablanca had in mind and why he
wasn't very happy with this game even
though he did win but he wanted to play
this one and he wouldn't be I mean they
wouldn't award the brilliancy prize to
him if he didn't show this wonderful
line after the game finished but yeah
and for those of you who are maybe new
to this channel maybe you are not
familiar with that game confit caroli
vs. Michael tall where Michael Tao also
wasn't happy with the line károlyi
played because it ruined his brilliancy
then he also had to present his line
after the game I will put a link to it
in the description below it will be the
first thing you will see so do check it
out it's quite a lovely game and also I
would like to invite everyone to check
out an impression video by the grand KHS
classic video team the kinetic HS
classic is starting very soon so you
know we are expecting a lot of high
quality footage from every round and
this is before the main event even
started but it's a wonderful impression
it lasts two minutes so do check it out
it will be the second link in the
description below so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and I also have a
special announcement
for this video I have a a birthday wish
for mr. James Noel here we have it his
girlfriend sent me this photo
it's him watching one of my videos and
as you can see for some reason every
time someone screenshot or takes a photo
of my video video I always have this
weird expression on my face but you know
it's just the way it is I can help it
but ya know I wish you a very happy
birthday mr. James Noble and you know I
really hope you had a great one yeah
that's it for this game kappa blanka
still undefeated in the new york rice
tournament of 1916 out of ten games nine
wins and one draw next game he faces
Borislav Kostich a legend chess player
but we were gonna get back to that I
would like to thank Liu Liu Shui Kong
Thomas Jaeger and the nd Proudfoot
Clinton fuller and Tony Moore guitar for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
I think all for watching and I will see
you soon continue in a couple blocks
saga we're preparing for the cranky
chess classic and of course
as usual checking up on your suggestions
I think your I will see soon and have an
excellent rest of your weekend